[موسيقى]
في جنوب غرب تركيا يقع
ساحلها المذهل موطنًا للشواطئ المثالية
وعجائب الزيتون التاريخية
والمدن الساحلية الساحرة، وقد انجذب الناس إلى هذه
المياه منذ
العصور القديمة وهناك رجل واحد يعرفها
أكثر من أي شخص آخر. صباح الخير للجميع،
أه اليوم نحن  سنذهب إلى أحد أفضل
مواقع الغوص في كوشاد الاسم هو
أداك أه مركبة غوص الكهف اسمي تي
ساراتشو أنا مدرب غوص ومالك
مركز غوص ولد في إزمير
ونشأ في كوشا كان ديس تامات يبلغ من
العمر 14 عامًا عندما اكتشف  شغفه
بالغوص تحت أعين رجاله الساهرة
لقد تعلم قدر استطاعته حتى
بلغ 18 عامًا عندما أصبح بإمكانه أن يصبح مدرب غوص
بنفسه لمدة 28 عامًا، وهو يساعد الآخرين على
اكتشاف عجائب
العان تحت الماء عندما أغوص في مكان ما بالطبع  في
كوساداسي، هذا هو منزلي الذي ولدت فيه في هذه
المنطقة عندما أغوص هنا أعرف الجميع
ويمكنني إعطاء التوجيهات لكل شخص
يمكنك رؤيته هنا، فنحن نعلمهم كيف
يحبون
تحت الماء ولهذا السبب عندما أقوم بالغوص
أكون سعيدًا جدًا لأنك نسيت  كل ما لديك من
ضغوط، كل مشكلة مشكلة العمل، إذا كان
لديك شيء فقدته، نسيته
عندما ينزل الغواصون إلى اللون الأزرق،
يكشف سحر الآن عن
نفسه الرؤية هنا
لا تصدق تقدم رؤية واضحة
للعجائب تحت الماء أسفل
هذه الكهوف المخفية  عالم ينتظر
الاستكشاف نغوص هناك حوالي 14 م
ونزور نفق واحد داخل الكهف وواحد
أه نغوص في الكهف مع النفق الأول
نستخدم أه المشاعل ونرى الجمبري
العديد من المرجان الأصفر والأحمر لون
المرجان وأه نرى العديد من الأنواع المختلفة
من الأسماك رأينا أخطبوطًا واحدًا وبعد ذلك
قمنا بزيارة أه
الغوص في الكهف لتامات كل غوص في العان
هي مغامرة فريدة من نوعها
ومشاركة ذلك مع الآخرين
هي شغف حياته إنه أمر جيد حقًا
لا أحد من حولك يلعب الصمت
تستمتع به تحت الماء مع الأسماك
أحيانًا أنا  فكر جيدًا ربما أكون سمكة
لأنني طوال اليوم تحت
الماء للغوص، فأنا أحب الغوص حقًا